guess what cast from a hit Netflix show
is coming in for a puppy interview today
when prepping for a shoot the first
thing we do is get the set ready with
the backdrop then we move on to cameras
and lighting we do a few Lighting and
Sound tests before getting in some of
our own puppy play time before the cast
gets here and today was the Outer Banks
cast here to talk all about season three
did you guess it right the cast was
super sweet and so fun to work with it
was definitely a big task to pry the
puppies away from them at the end of the
day but who could blame them make sure
to watch the entire outer banks puppy
interview on BuzzFeed celeb now